probably time time Love Actually is a
modern holiday classic that looks at
Hugh Grant's tenure as prime minister
and investigates just how difficult it
is for beautiful people to find love
around the holidays it's a wonderful
family movie for waitin Irma it's a
heartwarming or rated movie and we'll
watch hint we all have some questions if
Prime Minister Grant didn't walk in on
president Slingblade kissing his
secretary would he have never stood up
to him and why does everyone in the
movie refer to Natalie as fat when she
caught early isn't he cool I think
there's a pretty sizable ass there yes
sir
what are these people how long does it
take to set up lighting for a porn shoot
it's been like four weeks and why do I
always forget about this part when
suggesting to watch this movie with my
family how did the bride and groom not
notice that half the people at their
wedding where strangers concealing wind
instruments and what kind of creepy
person organizes his own surprise at
someone's wedding oh and what kind of
person spends the entire wedding filming
the bride in an extreme close-up and who
shows up at a newly married couples door
on Christmas Eve to tell the bride that
has wasted heart will love her until
she's a shriveled up corpse it's a self
preservation oh and isn't that Rick from
The Walking Dead are institutionalized
mental patients able to use the phone at
all hours and is this guy flexing his
triceps here or is that just how it
looks when muscular people make regular
movements no I don't really have a
question here just really like the fans
no actually no here's a question when
the prime minister plays music and in
the bedroom does the entire house have
to listen to it if the teachers are so
reluctant about participating the
Christmas show why do they position
themselves in the front row why is it
really his father so mean to his other
daughter didn't the filmmakers worried
that this foolproof plan for getting
past the airport security would wind up
in the hands of terrorists did Snape and
his wife get a divorce or are they still
together is the Prime Minister usually
fly commercial or is that a new program
that Prime Minister Grant instituted and
most importantly where is all these
people get their turtlenecks
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]